foreign
comes from Wayne in Pennsylvania right
now what would be the best investment in
stocks to invest in if there's a
downturn coming if the government does
not raise the debt ceiling in June and
we go into a recession what is the best
thing to do with our money hmm
uh well Wayne I mean I would say the I
mean honestly we're still so consistent
regardless of what downturn is happening
especially when it comes to investing if
you are out of debt with a fully funded
emergency fund
you still want to be investing I mean
even in a downturn and especially in the
downtown yeah we've we've had ups and
downs and what happens a lot of people
have a lot of fear and they freak out
and so they either stop investing or
they pull their money out at the bottom
which is actually the best time to
invest because then you get to ride all
the gains when it goes back up and so I
would be very consistent Wayne on what
you're doing I mean you know we talk
about retirement a lot 401ks uh Roth
IRAs you know good mutual funds within
those and and just continue the path now
you know if you are in a position and
you know with a recession I mean the job
market and stuff you know that's
sometimes where you see
um significant possible layoffs and that
kind of thing so if you're in an
environment a company or an industry
that layoffs are happening and you have
a three-month emergency fund maybe I
would probably pump it up to six you
know you can be conservative on the same
on the savings end to get to money but
other than that I mean I would I would
keep investing but in June is when the
debt ceiling Dave comes into comes into
effect and so there's that whole
conversation going on
and so when you look at that
what are what are your thoughts around
all that I yawn
it's happened so many times in my 62
years
that they get up to them and they're
just gonna raise it right I mean what
are they going to do yeah I know of
course they're going to raise it like a
hundred percent of the time they raise
the debt ceiling because they just can't
keep quit spending they spend like
they're drunk and on drugs I mean they
just spend all the time up there and so
they're going to raise it of course
they're gonna raise it but there's gonna
politically posture around and act like
it's somebody's fault it's not
somebody's fault it's your fault and my
fault because we elected those idiots
and we keep sending them up there and
they keep doing the same stupid butt
stuff over and over and over again
they're gonna raise it and even if they
don't for three weeks and they have to
set some federal workers aside or some
kind of crap like that like they do a
time or two I can remember I think it's
happened twice or three times in my life
but every so often we get this thing but
it's Democrats versus Republicans and
I'm going to push through my little
agenda in order to not hold I'm going to
hold the nation hostage so I can get my
little little political crap into the
bill and that's what we're doing and
that's what we're seeing up there right
now at this moment yeah as always so
they're going to pass it and and even if
they don't it's not going to throw the
nation into a recession where'd you get
that that's just wrong it's not going to
do that so all of that aside question is
yeah your core question is what do we
invest in I invest in four types of
Mutual Funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international I
prefer mutual funds that have at least a
10-year track record and all of the ones
I currently own do and uh and I invest
in those in up times and down times in
all times I never stop I never stop I
never stop I invest all the way down I
invest all the way up I am always
looking like I'm the smartest person on
the planet and the only intelligent
thing I did was I didn't stop and I just
keep investing and I just keep investing
and I just keep investing and we've
found all kinds of research that says
the number one correlating factor to
people who build wealth investing is
that they act actually invest consistent
they don't sit and discuss whether the
debt ceiling is going to knock them out
or whether the dollar is going to get
blown up or whether the chimney oh the
dead gum drama that goes around the
economy all the time okay well the other
drama piece you mentioned it but the
word recession it's bad I mean it's it's
a it's one that's floated around for a
while and a lot of people are saying I
wish there's something that you can see
consecutive quarters of the GDP going
down that's a recession
if you say it with Movie music in the
background
a recession recession report live on CNN
or Fox
it's the recession we're following the
recession
and then it didn't actually happen
it's kind of anticlimactic you know and
so or the recession happens and the
economy was down one quarter of one
percent
two consecutive
quarters
and so it's technically a recession that
totals a half a percent of shrinkage
I mean really
I can tell you something that had a
whole lot more effect on it its name was
fauci okay he had a lot more impact on
your economy and on your dad gum
the mesh that you call inflation now the
inflation crap is real but recession
yeah
guys listen there's always a newscaster
whose job is to scare your butt because
you don't watch unless you're mad or
scared
and if you're mad or scared not true you
go down the rabbit hole and keep
watching and keep watching and keep
watching and you study all the theories
and all the reasons that everything that
we've worked for is just going to
evaporate and we're all going to die and
this trauma this fear porn is just real
I'm not making fun of Wayne I'm making
fun of me and Rachel and everybody else
we all do this we all do this you're the
conspiracy theory Queen of the family of
course so you know we all do this and so
you get you just you get sucked into
this you get sucked into this Freudian
negative scarcity fear-based stuff and
it it keeps you the reason I'm going off
on it is it keeps you from investing yes
yes yes you have to just it's an act of
your will it's an act of your intellect
I'm just going to keep investing and the
ones that never stop for any reason they
just keep investing they're the tortoise
and they win every time I read the book